the live and Al live tour is off and
running Tulsa Oklahoma September 15th
and 16th Phoenix Arizona September 29th
and 30th get your tickets to all shows
at
ransler the Honeydew with Brian
[Music]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants Studios you know I'm Ryan
sichler ryan.com Ryan sichler on all
your social media and again every week
thank you this community continues to
grow the stories continue to get Wilder
um we're over 200,000 subscribers now on
YouTube which is awesome got a goal next
step's half a million so subscribe it
helps the podcast I'm telling you it's a
a free way to really help the show out
and if you got to have more then listen
you got to go check out the patreon now
we're over 5,000 subscribers there and
it continues to grow every month it gets
bigger and the story is there it's worth
it it's only five bucks there's no tiers
no levels no T-shirt cannons none of
that [__] it's just five bucks you get
the honey do a day early you get it ad
free you get it at no additional cost
and you get the entire back Library
audio and video of the Honeydew with
y'all and y'all got the wildest stories
if you or anyone you know out there has
a story that has to be heard please
submit it to honeydo podcast gmail.com
and if you looking for a new podcast to
listen to again go listen to my old
podcast to crab Feast that Community is
still thriving online and that library
is going to do over a million downloads
this year that's a podcast that's been
almost dead for 5 years that's that's
incredible so thank you guys for your
support all right come out and see me on
the road y'all the live and Al live tour
is live and well Tulsa I'm coming to see
you September 15th and 16th Phoenix
Arizona September 29th and the 30th I'll
be in Salt Lake City October 27th and
the 28th November 10th and 11th bavia
Illinois and then we're going to close
out the year in San Francisco on
December 8th and 9th get all your
tickets at Ryan .c now that's the biz
and you guys know what we're doing over
here we're highlighting the low lights I
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers I'm very excited to
have this guest on here ladies and
gentlemen first time on the Honeydew
please welcome Tom takar welcome to the
honey dudes hey thanks for having me
brother this is a dream being here love
well it's good to see you again I say
because the first time we really met was
when your epic special yeah I got to sit
across from you and interview and it's
been so long I barely remember anything
I know I remember that vividly because
it was for it's the only time I think a
man has made me cry and uh as an adult I
should say I was going to say we're
about to get into I've been D no I'm
just kidding no that's a weird way to
start I this is monetized right I don't
know it was it was it was uh yeah I was
like we're doing the a comedy special
and you interviewed me and you asked
some I don't even remember what it was
but I started talking about a friend of
mine being a good dad and I almost
started breaking out into tears and I
was like what the [__] am I what what is
this guy you're like white Oprah I'll
take it man I'll take white Oprah any
day well before we get in your story
today please plug promote everything
anything you'd like I'd love uh for
people to check out I just put out an
hour special it's free on YouTube so you
can click right over to it it's called
takar Noir D ha KK a r uh Noir uh like
jar Noir the the clog and it's an album
too but uh it's it's through 800lb
gorilla on YouTube and I'd love for
people to check that out it's an hour of
just jokes about some of the stuff we're
probably going to talk about today but
like I try to make it everything just
funny like there's no message there's no
like Le lecture in it or anything it's
just an hour of pure jokes and in a
comedy club that I think is really
strong so I'd love for people to check
that out all right where are they where
are you on social media and all that uh
I'm on Instagram and I a little bit on
Tik Tok are you on Tik I I can't I have
people do I I had to pay people to help
me out what's up I had to pay them to I
can't I got to pay somebody I was on it
for hours yeah and it's just killing my
day and you know I'd rather sit here and
do this with you sure than try to figure
out what's trending on this social media
app yeah and like having to figure out
what hashtag to use to make
a like a 15-year-old like me it's just
not it doesn't feel it should be illegal
like all Tik Tok feels like as me trying
to attract children into my uh into my
fan base and it doesn't it doesn't feel
right but Instagram feels a little bit
more like whatever so I'm on there at
Tom toar and then YouTube and all that
stuff now Facebook I guess if that's
still part of it Facebook's a huge part
of it oh my God huge yeah I need to
delve I'm I'm trying to get better all
this stuff yeah but and then I have a
podcast too called uh stand by your band
where we have comedians come on and
defend music that people make fun of and
it's h it's a good time yeah stand by
your band so let's get into your life a
little bit because I want to get to
refresh myself and I want everybody to
get to know you a little bit where are
you from originally I'm from Indiana
okay yeah yeah Bloomington Indiana to be
specific but more like the outskirt
because bloomington's a college town
that's hoers right but I'm not from the
collegey part I like to say I'm from P
like 20 minutes past the Walmart cuz
like that's a different part of the
world it's like toy culture but it's
like it's like the try that in a small
town type you know like it's that it's
that type of
[__] it's not like the college students
with uh you know their backpacks and
stuff it's like missing teeth and like
uh dirt uh dirt floor type [__] now we
didn't have that but like it was that's
the sort of uh part of town grew up in
yeah I don't know if you spent much time
in Indiana I spent quite a bit of time
in Indiana actually yeah I like Indiana
Indiana's all right I love Indiana I
should I I defend it now that I live in
like coastal cities and when we get out
here Kirsten was just there with me went
and saw my friends uh I went and did the
club there and my friends uh Austin and
Libby came out what's up y'all and they
um I took my shoes off I hadn't walked
in gr I hadn't had bare feet on grass in
so long sure there's space just seeing
grass and space
and I was just like God I miss this I
miss this the air is kind of nice it's
like it's it I have a when people are
like because I lived in New York for a
while and when people would be like
people in New York are pieces of [__]
they don't they treat you bad in the
midwest everybody's nice that's not
really true but there is a nice like
slowed down chilled out Vibe I like they
have real dive bars in Indiana where
it's like you could hang out with like a
hipster teen and a 70-year-old
like a career Drinker and that doesn't
exist as much in other parts of the
world I think or like coastal cities I
should say you know it's like real
people so growing up in Indiana what was
did your mom and dad did you have
siblings what do you I know cuz I know
from talking to you that your dad left
early I did not have a dad like from the
jump I had I had older brother and
sister when I was born from your mom or
from my mom uh from my dad I don't know
a lot lot like he's an Indian dude and
he your I get born she's not she's white
uh she's a a bunch of different white
[__] when people ask me I'm not like a
dude who's attached to my like I'm not
like I'm me and my family are you don't
[__] with us or Indian either I don't I
have a lot of problems with like I think
because I'm mix race I just don't give a
[__] about any of that stuff like I
don't care about Indian culture I don't
care about white culture or whatever
that is but like Irish Italian I don't
know it's a big mix of [__] uh and so I
don't care about that but like uh she's
not she's not Indian they met on in the
personal ads and went out on a few dates
had me out of it were never married or
anything person out of the paper back
out of the paper the old school
Craigslist yeah my aunt apparently was
supposed to meet this dude and she had
so many dates from the personal ads she
dumped him off under my mom and then uh
they is that right yeah yeah they this
is your biological father dumped your
aunt was like I got too much on my plate
why don't you take this one and it
turned into you turned into me
yeah yeah a weird little piece of print
in the newspaper turn
my a weird desperate Indian man in the
newspaper like please will anyone
[__] that's
me God that's so good okay so they meet
and is it was it I mean I'm not trying
to be disrespectful in anyway but was it
a one night you say he's gone was it a
one night stand so this is a tough thing
to get out of your mom she's not going
to say that right want to look yeah I
don't think it was a one night stand
from her the way she described it they
went on some dates it sounded like they
were kind of like casually dating from
what I understand they my mom famously
says he was like a cheap piece of [__]
he was a doctor when uh they met and uh
he took her to Wendy's with my aunt and
asked them to split a baked potato as
like their meal so it might be it's also
like one of the cheapest things you can
get there too truly cheap known for
their burgers yeah but you guys you
haven't had this potato yet you're
really pushing the potato I'm telling
you this is the best potato you're going
to have the burgers are
overrated so maybe then it kind of
sounds like they were dating for a
little while and then your mom says hey
I'm pregnant and he's like I'm [__]
out of here sort of I think there's some
of that I think he was I mean there's
multip people there's definitely some of
that yeah oh okay I see to tell you I
we're going to get really real here uh
there was like a lawsuit against him
that he was hooking up with his patients
and then coercing them to have abortions
so I was supposed to be an abortion he
was trying to get my mom to abort me
right out of the gate and he would do it
but at that time she wasn't a patient
they met because your no yeah she was a
patient but there was yeah yeah yeah
yeah at least there was a history of
this kind of doctor was he he was an
OBGYN so he given the abortion too
that's what that's what was I it's hard
for me to decipher all of it I found an
article once in the uh scandalous you
know that uh what's that newspaper
that's like uh bat boy or whatever the
weekly world news or something like that
it's all like hoaxes and [__] he was in
that the onion no no no okay no it's not
funny it's real this one's real this
one's real I mean it's like it's it's
like real but tabloid right right but uh
like The Inquirer and all that [__] yeah
kind of like that it's like it's like in
the 8 or the 90s when they'd be like
alien footage found or whatever and now
we're like maybe that was real yeah
right right uh anyways she he was like
featured in that apparently at some
point and so I found that at one point
in my 20s cuz I never met the guy uh so
I was like oh my God this guy's a pie
ofit were you looking for him no
at least I mean I never looked for him
uh my mom tried to find him when I right
before I turned 18 cuz he never played
he never paid child support and he was
what she remembered was he was a doctor
he lost his medical license and went to
jail for a while for some of this [__]
yeah for some of it she was like she was
like I think some of this was like small
town racism stuff I don't know how much
of it was real I think some people like
dated him and then didn't want to admit
it or something but also it's it's hard
to you never know what somebody's trying
to like hide from you to protect you
from the monster your father might have
been you know and so I never went
looking I always kind of thought yeah I
don't know if this makes sense but it's
like from an early age I was like if
this guy doesn't want a relationship
with me why would I be looking for him
you know yeah you're wired differently
though that's what I've learned about in
therapy too you're wired differently a
lot of people go the other way like I I
need this I need this closure I need
this sought it out in other ways like I
you know I wanted the respect of other
guys in my life like adults like guys I
have a bit about it now but it's like
not having it you do seek it out in ways
and now I have all these guys I'm not
going to do my bit but it's like I find
these old men on YouTube and they teach
you how to do stuff and I find that so
soothing and that is like my new dad
like I definitely want and in comedy
like listen I my I had a great dad he
died when I was 16 so from there on I
grow up without a dad and I I mean I
love my dad but I learned how to tie a
double [__] Windsor you know
what I'm saying I learned how to tie a
Cadillac of knots sure on YouTube that's
exactly that's exactly what my is you
who needs a dad who needs a dad that's
exactly I had to that's the exact
example I use is nobody taught me how to
tie a tie and then I found this guy and
uh now he's my dad but he's good dad he
doesn't bother me too much built a deck
last week he's got out there do cuz I
bought a house and I got to find these
guys and they're like here's how you get
rid of a wasp
nest I think your dad are supposed to
teach but uh I never thought to like
they're always angry too like here's how
you do it um but I didn't seek it out
because I was like if this guy doesn't
want a thing with me why would I want it
but then I got older and you just get
curious you know and then he it all came
back into my life when I was like 26 or
so cuz he died
and I only found out how' he die uh
that's a great question he was uh flying
back to India and um and he had some
sort of blood disorder of some kind I
probably should know out of like medical
indry my wife a guy who has that very
probably same blood disorder similar
with clotting and stuff MH I say this on
this show all the time I'm going to say
it again even if you don't talk to your
family if you don't man find out their
history their health history cuz it's
your no matter what that's your DNA code
in there and whatever they have you
could very well have and it could kill
you yeah but what if I find out I'm
gay just kidding uh get the abortion get
the
abortion no uh sorry that was dumb as
hell um no that should do that because
that's he died pretty young too I think
he was like 62 or something like that so
not young young young but like yeah I
hope I hope I get way past that me too
brother for both of us uh my wife is
like you should figure the [__] out but
I I really should I'm scared of f was he
on the plane when it went I think that's
where it started it's hard to really
gather all the details because there
were so many Shifty characters involved
in his death story because he was a big
ripoff artist he was a big like dirt bag
he kept all of his money in his house in
cash he lost his medical license opens a
blinds business and a miny car shop like
the oil change place
found out about all thisit because after
he died like months
pass and uh my mom had found him this is
kind of important my mom found him right
before I turned 18 to get a little bit
of child support and where was he was he
still in Georgia Georgia he was in
Georgia I thought he was back in India
or somewhere across the country he
stayed in the states yeah he was like
you know he was not far away he was in
Georgia uh he was in a suburb of Atlanta
and so uh I I just knew that he was
alive or whatever at that time when I
was 17 he sent us like 15 grand for my
entire life and uh and then I use some
of that to go to college and I never
thought of him again I was just like
whatever [__] this guy he knows that I'm
alive now he paid child support it he
did not make an effort to reach out [__]
him like I just I had a great mom so I
was like I don't need this guy uh cut
two he dies three months after he dies I
my family gets a call because he has all
these lawsuits against like XY lives
ex-girlfriends like other business
partners and the [__] and they want me
as The Only Living Air to drop the
lawsuits but I don't even know this
exists I don't even I don't know he was
dead so I'm learning all this [__] on
the Fly what do you mean to drop them
like they think I can take over the law
like his estate and because he has
lawsuits against these people I can take
it over he the yeah he's like suing a
woman over a house like all this so
saying over just drop all this exactly I
only find out he died because of
somebody trying to do that and so my
uncle looks into it he's a lawyer and
he's like hey I think there's like a big
estate here that seems to have just been
left behind for four months let's go
figure this out and so what had happened
is after he died he had an attorney and
some other lady like an accountant who
became the executives of this state
because they pretended they didn't know
I was alive even though he there was
documents that showed they did because I
they paid child support when I was 17
and so they were they had drained the
estate dry they sold everything to
themselves they he had two Porsches they
sold to themselves for like a grand uh
because they were just running wild and
so we tried to like fight it for a
little bit but it was [__] uh but for
a second I was going to move to uh to
Georgia and Ona miniki that was the
other thing is they were like this
miniki is falling apart there's nobody
to take care I was like 25 and I was I
was like yeah I'll move to Atlanta with
my buddies and take over this house and
uh and run a mini while I do stand up on
the side I don't think they're in
business anymore I don't I think it's
all gone I mean this I'll this I'll tell
you what happened to me one time in a
and it's a positive and this is a good
little [__] you to your dad then I went
to a minii and they're like hey if you
open up a line of credit you can get x
amount and I had no money at the time I
was like sure I open up the credit they
do the whole Muffler from the converter
back all that [__] and uh it's on my
1990 Honda Civic with original rims oh
hell yeah and beautiful car thank you
and then they go under within like a
week yeah and I don't know what happened
I even called the check but I guess the
paperwork never went through and I got
all of that done for free oh that's the
best I called to try to be honest and
pay we don't have any record of it I was
like
that's the best you try and you're still
like I was like look I'm trying to be
honest like we don't have any record
we'll notify you if we do funny that you
had like a miky credit card that is not
bro I had a miky credit card I don't
know if it was really a c walk
around like a chuckecheese credit card
like you do not need this if you uh good
for good for you and [__] my dad [__]
your dad but yeah so uh so you end up
losing that to the executiv of the will
and everything yep ended up with nothing
uh I I tried to have a now that I think
about it I'm getting pissed off again
but no not really I kind of let go of it
quick because I was like that's money I
never really counted on anyway you never
had it yeah you never had it it wasn't
real yeah exactly um but he had 100
grand in cash in his house did you get
that I did not I found out because his
buddy who who he worked with was like he
told me he's like did you find the 100
Grand in the house and I was like they
didn't let me in the house and then uh
he told the lawyer exeutive about it and
they didn't report it and then they were
like what are you talking about and then
they told him that they found it and
then the next time he saw him they were
like so he was like what happened with
that 100 Grand they what 100 Grand and
they just took it they just pocketed it
uh yeah he was I mean this is the
problem if I could recommend anything
don't have a piece of [__] dad who
that's where it starts doesn't think of
[__] like that but whatever like I said
it's money that I never accounted for I
was like this guy's not even in my life
it's a guy is a this guy a guy getting
women pregnant and then giving them
abortions
supposedly allegedly is is quite a
[__] piece of [__] yeah yeah not a
great guy and I'm glad I trying to get
your mom to not even have you at the
time yeah she according to her she was
uh really had to like play defense to
stop an abortion from happening like she
really had to stop like make sure I'm I
thought I was the only one who of his
kids that didn't get aborted it turns
out there was one other and I found this
out in the same phone call I found out
that he was dead because they were like
hey uh you are they're like hey your
dad's dead you got a brother named Kenny
and he's dead he's dead too that's what
they did yeah that's what they did they
go they did exactly that they go they go
uh it looks like they said it so
casually too as if I I learned I got a
brother and then I learned he was dead
do you remember who it was it was an
attorney it was somebody who worked at
the court in Georgia and they were like
okay uh there's there's uh news here it
looks like you are the only living a oh
uh there uh there is a brother uh he did
die in a car
accident what the [__] I was like the
second you hear you have a brother like
oh [__] I might meet this oh my God he's
gone I've lost him uh so he's dead uh
and
yeah I never met him I didn't because I
didn't meet any of these but he's
another I think another half Indian dude
uh but he W he did grow up with my
father so it's like it was a weird thing
oh he did yeah he was in my father's
life so it was a different it was a
different thing you know and so I was
like man it's a real bummer this dude's
dead because it would be very
interesting to get to know him and like
so to your to the best of your knowledge
it's just two siblings out of your
father father yeah just me and him yeah
that's there might be some the way he
lived his life he might have there might
have been a few more but okay at least
I'm the only one who uh slipped through
you know and then do you have a stepdad
who comes in if your dad your dad's gone
from day one so at what age does your
mom remarry does she just date what does
she do yeah my mom remarries when I'm
two was this from another dude your ass
putting [__] although it is a setup
my mom worked at Red LOB
oh [__] my stepdad down the street there
was a Jiffy Lube we're moving up what's
up with these what's up with your
mom something about a guy your mom loves
a man in an oil lay under a
car uh and not my they're still in
business doing all right still in
business that Jiffy Lube's still there I
think um I think Jiffy Lube if I'm I'm
wrong a lot but I think they're the
company that started the whole [__]
3,000 miles oh I think it was their
marketing campaign that did that made
you think because it's in my head all
the time but also of course if I don't
need to change my oil for 7500 but I'm
doing it every three of course my car is
going to run great of course it is but
you don't need to do that you probably
don't need to Lear you don't need to at
all like you can go for 10,000 miles I'm
like 10,000 miles that's that's three
and a half chy Lo changes and it's
expensive too I mean not in small towns
but uh here it's [__] it's like a 100
bucks it's a lot for an O CH I got to
learn how to do this [__] myself it
doesn't matter didn't have a your dad
did have a he had a vision let's just
say he had a vision he had a vision
sometimes I dress for Comfort sometimes
for style and I found my new favorite
pants that I can wear at any time
anywhere are from doer my doer pants are
the most comfortable pair of pants I own
and not only do they feel great but they
look great too they're black pants I
wear them on stage all the time you see
me if you see me in black pants those
are doer pants and you're going to see
me in black pants a lot do a stretch
performance Denim and lifestyle apparel
is made to do what's comfortable their
denim has five times the stretch of
traditional rigid denim they're designed
to keep you cool and dry in any
temperature and they are antibacterial
for easy Care Plus they're made with the
environment in mind using sustainable
materials that are designed to last
trust me you haven't felt Comfort until
so you have your own pair of doers check
out doers Flagship stores in La and
Denver or shop online at shop.com I've
arranged something special with doer
just for my listeners 15% sitewide when
you use my promo code honeydew this is
an awesome deal because doer never goes
on sale so don't miss out for 15% off go
now to shopd do.com that's shop
du.com and use my promo code honeydo
shopd do.com
promo code honeydew now let's get back
to the D uh step stepdad's Jiffy he
comes around into the picture when I'm
like two so I thought he was my dad
gotcha uh I did not know he wasn't and
until how old when do you find that out
I learned young because I was uh I
remember I was like four years old and
all my earliest memories of of him
because he was terrifying he was a
violent alcoholic bipolar but not
diagnosed until we were older uh and I
remember we walk into his his grandma's
uh place we're staying with my great
grandma for the weekend on his side and
I walk in and I'm like four and I'm all
excited to see her she hated me and I
didn't you know when an adult hates you
and you don't clock it because you're
like what an insane thing to hate a
four-year-old and also you're confused
cuz you're like I feeling is just am I
you even before you fully have that
awareness of like oh people cannot like
you like there are a lot of people in
this world who are going to hate you um
but we walk in she's immediately
[__] part of it is I'm half Indian
and like this is a part of IND these are
she's 100% racist and she
was she was and like a lot of people be
like you don't pass as Indian but it's a
kid like in Indiana at that age it
doesn't matter what you like in your
blood yeah you got a good at that age in
Indiana they don't like you blud blood
they were on their Harry Potter
[__] so I walk in and I'm like uh oh my
dad's in the car and I'm talking about
my stepdad and she goes what what your
dad is in the car and I he comes in it's
my stepdad and I go see it's my dad and
she was like that's not your [__] dad
that's how you found out what and so
then my mom told me she denies this she
says I'm mixed up but I remember this
vividly maybe I mix it up but she told
me uh she pointed at the newspaper uh
and said this is your dad and it was a
picture of Bobby Knight the basketball
coach throwing a chair it was a picture
of him and so I went to school and told
everybody bob Knight was my real dad and
for like a year and they were like
you're a F everybody thought I was like
slow or something and so uh I looked
like a dumbass when I found out that uh
that that was not the truth cuz that I
mean I'm from the town that that from
Bobby Knight country man from Bobby KN
saying that sounds insane it's like it's
like saying Neil Armstrong is my like I
don't it's insane yeah uh but anyway
yeah I found out pretty early he was not
my real dad and he also made you feel
like he was very resentful of me growing
up he was like had a lot of jealousy he
would think that I was he thought that I
thought I was better than him or
something he like I was pretty good in
school and if I was good at something he
was like you think you're [__]
smarter than me that type of [__] I
don't know I think because I wasn't his
kid he felt like a weirdness even though
I was he's there since I was two so it's
like kids don't have that in their brain
like I [__] hate my stepdad when
you're two all you know he's bringing
all that energy yeah yeah so uh yeah
it's not a great father figure how long
is he in your life still wow he's still
in my life is he still married to your
mom he is yeah is he going to listen to
this
maybe I don't know he watches all my
[__] now he's actually become a big fan
it's
weird it's weird I mean to be fair it's
like now I'm older I you know I I don't
hold like I try not to hold resentment
about stuff but it [__] me up like it
[__] you up does he do [__] up [__]
he told me he was going to like he would
kill our pets and stuff like what he's a
psycho yeah what do you mean he uh would
I mean not like our not like our you
know dogs or whatever he was abusive to
animals all the stuff that like you hear
like serial killers do or whatever he
was doing that [__] he poisoned like
cats and stuff in the neighborhood like
random cats and you knew this yeah he
told me it [__] scared the [__] out
of me he we had pet rats and he smashed
one in the head one night and told I was
like where did Rex go that was the name
of the Rat I love this rat and he goes
oh I [__] smashed its head in last
night so I was terrified of this dude he
would get drunk he'd drink 30 natural
lights that's why I don't drink natural
lights [__] it's for animal abusers
serious I hope you're not trying to get
sponsored by natural light he he would
kill pets he would kill pets yeah and
tell you about tell me about it to scare
me we had rabbits that I found out that
he slaughtered just for the fun of it
like not to eat no no he didn't have
that type of skills to like fle and
[__] no no uh no he like SL this he's
just being sick he
like thr out or he was hammered I think
come across any of this did you ever see
any it no but I found out years later uh
now I'm like maybe I shouldn't be
talking about this [__] but uh what
we're here we're doing it uh but no it's
it scared the [__] [__] out of me
like and then he told me one night he
was like uh cuz he would get drunk and
as I was getting older I would be the
one he would like take [__] out on but
he would also confide [__] in me he'd be
like if my mom like was shitty to him
one day he would she would go to work at
night and I'd just be stuck in the house
with a maniac literally yeah yeah and I
had uh you know a couple younger
siblings in the house three three and
then older ones the old ones got out but
I remember he he threw an ice pick at my
older sister and stabbed her with it
what yeah yeah uh and so she moved out
quick like uh she had it rough but then
I'm just in the house yeah yeah yeah uh
it was I mean of these children his
biological kids only my my two younger
brothers are his biological uh kids yeah
but uh and your mom and him are still
married they are still married yeah and
she knows about the ice pick and the
Animals I all of it she's like uh
connected to you know what I mean uh
it's it's a tricky situation I hate to
like I love her I hate to like uh you
know divulge any of her [__] like or
like speculate on her stuff but they are
they are still married and it's uh it's
a weird it's a weird Stitch because I
still see him sometimes yeah and like I
said now he's like he's like oh I saw
your YouTube like he shows his my videos
to his friend when I The Tonight Show
and like Conan oh he's like using me to
like brag to his friends now and I want
to be like [__] like I Trixie
yeah yeah they cut a bit out of my epic
special where I had a joke about like
wanting him to kill himself and then I
was like and and uh the producer of it
was like what the [__] are you talking
about that's like my favorite bit in the
thing and I was like I'm scared or
whatever but then it's like you get
older and you're like this should
happened you should have the right to
talk about it if it happened not only
that here's the thing man people back
then never even considered that they
could abuse this group of people
children whatever and then that those
kids would grow up to sit behind
microphones in front of cameras and tell
the story of what happened to them and
now there's a certain group of these
adults that are like yeah oh [__] I know
but it's like I wonder if they even
connect to it like sometimes I dream of
like calling him up and being like what
do you think about everything that
happened like do you remember he still
do that does he still drink like that I
don't know I got I moved out when I was
18 and like tried to get away from what
I understand he seems to have mellowed
out my mom is always like he's mellowed
way out like he's he just like hangs out
at home now and like watches like uh
Matt lock and [__] he just watches rerun
to Andy G for the show and stuff he
seems to be way more melow out I don't
know if he has that streak in him
anymore but I will like I'm sometimes
like I should I like I thought for a
minute of like maybe I'll do a podcast
where I like talk to him and then I was
like this is too intense also not every
[__] thing has to be content not
everything needs to be content and a
podcast you're right that could be a
phone call I would make a phone call
stay away I think it was the only way I
could like wrap my head around actually
talking to him because I was like maybe
if he thinks it's like fun or something
I don't know but it's like I I it's it
[__] you up like he told me he told me
as a young kid like if you guys leave I
will find you and kill you like that
sort of [__] so I lived into my 20s
[__] fear [__] dude that's what he
would say yeah he said I
will stuff as a kid he said if you if
you tell your mom I will also like CU
that'll make her want to leave and then
that then I will kill you and he had
this gun in the house that like was this
daunting thing all the time like a
shotgun or a pistol uh pistol yeah
handgun and like he would I shot it once
uh he was like oh it's fun I got this
gun and then it very quickly became like
a threat like he was like I have that
gun you know what I can do with it
whatever and then once a month he would
get depressed cuz it's bipolar [__] and
he would go stand in the yard and like
hold the gun to his head and I was the
only kid I was the oldest kid in the
house so I would have to go out there
and be like please don't kill yourself
are you serious yeah yeah this is like a
once a month sort of thing once a month
yeah yeah yeah it's like the rent and
it's like his
period maybe that was it maybe he was
supposed to be
transgender and this was his way of this
is the problem with not letting trans
people do their thing is then you have
guys like this no I'm G to get myself
canceled on this [__] show uh no it's
uh yeah I would have to convince him
like Hey you're we all you're a cool guy
don't kill yourself and and where you're
living in Indiana is it far enough out
that you don't have neighbors on either
side close enough that they're seeing
them stand out there they probably could
it was anyone coming over to help you or
talk to you everybody's minding their
business everybody's doing their own
thing we it's not a friendly
neighborhood that we live in it's also
acoss the street he is white dude uh
that sounds like white dude [__] this is
white no he was Dominican and uh came
out to Indiana he was a baseball player
no he was a classic white dude very
proud of like German [__] did he own the
Jiffy Lube no hold on I didn't mean to
jump over that very proud of German [__]
I just heard too he always like tells
about German food and stuff and he was
like yeah it's I I don't not that he was
like into Nazi [__] necessarily but like
he was
racist he was for sure racist but uh
yeah he was uh yeah he was racist don't
you find it fascinating that cuz I know
some guys back in from Maryland that
were racist and then they marry a
Dominican woman or something like that
I'm
like how do you how do you always talk
about the darker skin color uhhuh and
how you dislike it and then you marry
this lady and then have children with
her sure and then you continue that
racism but your kid even weirder yeah
it's like right it's like
the r yeah I found the one good one of
those not one of those can't even say it
whatever whatever the [__] she is I
found the good one I found the good one
okay I think she might have been uh
she's white in her heart or whatever
she's got a white
heart yeah it's Bonkers when you see
that and you do see it racist stepdad
yeah but I mean you know he's Indian
yeah I mean that wasn't great he's with
a white woman but you're not white so
maybe part of that is why he's taking
[__] out on you too yeah it could be I
think it was all more self I don't think
it was ever really about me I think it
was all insecurities and of course I say
that now is I've just realized it's like
yeah of course that was it doesn't make
any your biological father left that was
all you that was all you that was I made
a face the wrong face when I came out he
goes this guy you even need to make a
face as soon as your mom said I'm
pregnant he's like [__] that no you're
not I can feel this kid's Vibe you're
the reason he left legit you are the
reason say something [__] up mentally
maybe I didn't connect the right way so
what is it like having does this guy
come into like your high school events
does he show up are you embarrassed you
bring friends to the house school events
no we're not doing any of that [__] none
that because my mom worked nights you're
not going to prom I went to prom that
was the one thing I did I didn't go to a
homecoming you play sports I wanted to
play sports really bad I tried uh and I
I was able to play once I turned 16 cuz
then I could drive so I played soccer
when I was like 17 I wanted to play
basketball I was too fat to make the
team it was Ru my life you don't look I
was a heavier kid and also I'm just not
very tall or anything and my team my
high school team was very good they won
state in Indiana I mean you better be
[__] good if you're playing
especially in Bloomington Indiana or
even near that area exactly very bird
countryball good out there um it's in uh
everywhere else it's just basketball is
what they say but uh I wanted to do that
[__] I couldn't do really after school
stuff because I didn't have a ride
because my stepdad would get off work
and he would be hammered by you know
5:30 and he would his his excuse was
always like that he had bad Vision at
night but it's like Yeah man cuz you're
[__] blurry eyed I don't know what it
is but I'm seeing two things all the
time I see double yeah did he tried to
teach me how to drive but he was
drinking in the car and he was like you
got to drive faster man you're creeping
everybody out you're going to get us
pulled over he taught me how to drive
you're going to get us pulled over I was
going like 10 under and he's like you're
you're driving like a weirdo you're
driving like a drunk guy you gotta you
got to drive
normal yeah but no he wasn't coming to
any type of [__] like I had a friend
over once and he freaked the friend out
so was like we just didn't do that ever
again yeah I bet yeah uh yeah nobody met
this dude he was like my secret like
terrifying stepdad and so it made me a
[__] weirdo at school too CU I didn't
go out to stuff and then you know you're
up till 3 in the morning trying to
convince a guy not to kill himself and
you on the school bus you're like [__] I
didn't finish my homework last night
because I had to do my home work like I
had to come up with excuses for a
middle-aged man not to to kill himself
Jesus and you're not telling anyone that
at school no
guidance I eventually started talking
about it when I was like 14 I went
through I think the phase like people
get into at some point where I it turned
from Fear to anger when I was like 16 or
15 so then it's like you're kind of
looking for a fight at some point you're
also you're scre stronger you're 16
exactly you're like lifting weights
you're like I I think I could [__]
fight this 28 natties in I'm going [__]
this dudee but I would do little [__]
like he would [__] up and then I started
pouring out all all of his booze and he
wouldn't say [__] to me because he knew
like but he would the problem is he
would do all this [__] and he would get
so drunk he would forget right and then
the next day it's like why the [__] are
you in a bad mood to me and I'm like do
you not remember everything you [__]
did last night you psycho like just
throwing beer bottles against the wall
he like pointed a gun at me a couple
times held the knife to my [__]
throat it's like why are you pissed off
I don't know man why is your mom still
with she G she was at she was at work
you know uh but you know it's scary I
don't know like why does anybody stay
anywhere you know uh it's not easy to
told her the same thing you ever leave
I'll [__] come kill you maybe it's
also life is long maybe he's chilled
maybe he just never showed or that side
I don't know like different people have
different relationships and stuff but I
was [__]
terrified uh
and it's one of those things like you
you do the show obviously this is a
great [__] show you're able to make
humor out of this stuff this is the one
thing I've had a really hard time doing
on stage like I do my fir the album I
just put out the tarir thing a lot of
it's about my father stuff and like
being had like not having an Indian
father around that stuff took me a
minute to figure out this when I say the
[__] about like he killed the pets or
whatever I'm like this is not people are
not laughing and it's really hard for
for me to get over the hump you know
what I mean I would uh from just
experience on podcast in general over
all these years anytime something's
mentioned about animals dude it's over
you could I've had people come on here
talk about killing a person and people
like that's a great episode you talk
about an animal or something it's
disturbing yeah so it's like i' wouldd
almost rather say that he killed a
person on stage they beas it would be
more palatable than
he that's the sort of thing like don't
wrong I don't think that's funny at all
but it's I need to say
this cuz I had this bit about like I
wish my said would kill himself or
whatever like that's not the joke but
it's a joke and it sometimes it would
murder but sometimes people would be
looking at me like what the [__] are you
talking why would you I love my stepdad
why would you say that and it's trying
to figure out a way to
explain the horror or like the piece of
[__] itness to set up all of the funny
stuff that I can say after that you know
what I mean I don't know hey good luck
thanks I really thought you'd have the
answers
brother I really thought you'd have the
answer to I don't know about how you
dancing around murdering animals up
there cuz he ain't hunting you know what
I'm it's tough by the way I hope this
isn't too intense I know I know this is
the show but it's also I might be too
much show you're not too much he was too
much you're just tell it's not like you
did this that's a thing that does piss
me off about like the limitations of
sometimes where it's like people are
like man I just like comedians who talk
about their family and stuff and it's
like it's [__] up that just because of
how the circumstances are if I do that
I'm labeled a dark like this like dirty
Dark comic and it's like no I just I'm
trying to do the same thing everybody
else is trying to tell you what happened
in my life growing up yeah your seemed a
little different over there your seems a
little different yeah what um so what
what age do you leave then at 18 is that
when you finally get out 18 and it's
weird it's like it was a real bummer cuz
I really love to living with my mom my
mom is very funny my mom's a cool like
wonderful mom she had to work at night
like just keep us afloat you know uh we
didn't have what he do he not hold job
no he just worked at he worked at jiy
lube and then uh but he was able to he's
a functioning alcoholic that's what I
mean he was able to stay you have to do
a whole lot to work at those spots no
offense to the people who work at those
but like you can kind of ride the line
and he was the type of drunk who
normally I think he would be asleep by
like 10:30 11 some nights it was like he
could go till 4: and make me like listen
to music with him like held me hostage
and I was like dog I have [__] school
tomorrow and so that was a zombie but
like I did when I turned 18 I had an
opportunity to move in with a buddy
right before I went to college and I
went to school in Bloomington so I went
to IU and so uh to save like to save
money and [__] but my buddy was like do
you want to move into this apartment and
I was like not g to do it and then he
really like egged me on for it and then
I did and it's the best thing I've ever
done with my life cuz like I didn't
realize how
much every night worrying about whether
Dr Jackal or Mr Hyde was going to come
out was affecting me and then when
you're like you get to figure out who
you are a little bit like in the world
because I was like carrying that every
day and then I was I went to
college and I was like oh I'm I can
become like a normal guy now like I can
just not think about this [__] at all
and of course you're still thinking
about it in the back of your head or
every time you go home but uh yeah it
was a dream uh like I I went to college
started doing improv figured out like oh
I can be social on top of it because
when all that shit's happening at home
too I was not a social kid yeah like I
mean I had friends and stuff but I
wasn't like Bell of the ball I was like
a weirdo with dark [__] raccoon eyes
coming to school and uh and so yeah I
got to open up and then uh started
comedy got engaged super young uh I was
21 I think okay 21 or 22 and
uh it was a girl I was like super into
like a it was my first real real
girlfriend and I worked at the hospital
with her night shifts and we both went
to IU she graduates early uh I was
supposed to move to LA out of college to
do an internship at Jimmy Kimmel because
I had a pipeline from IU and instead uh
she begged me to move to Ohio where she
was going to med school she was like
come do this and so I was like well you
know I'm an Indiana kid a ro I was like
a romantic [__] little [__] and uh I
was like okay
I'll move to Ohio I'll move to LA once
you're done with med school it's all
good and then I we'll have our careers
and then I mve there and she very
quickly is like we were moving way too
fast like oh we got engaged right before
I moved okay and she's like we're moving
way too fast we're too young she's right
by the way but at the time it's like all
right well I moved to Ohio you did have
me move here and then eventually I'm
going I'm driving two hours to do open
mics to try to stay sane I'm working
night shift at a hospital in a a hotel
like alternating trying to stay afloat
while figuring out what I'm doing and
then in that time she ends up cheating
on me with this dude she goes to med
school with oh how do you find out I
found out it was a weird thing I had
some weird little suspicions she was
hanging out with this guy a lot and she
originally tried to set this dude up
with her friend and what's up with all
these weird setups in your life these
women in these setups setups are bad
yeah uh this guy working a [__] uh
quick quick
Express left
Midas he works at Pet Boys he's in the
whole shop he does it all full service
and he did uh no he uh he goes to med
school with her they're hanging out all
the time I see one night he they uh work
at Buffalo Wild Wings together at night
to like it's like a side job in med
school and I I am there with her one
night she's a little drunk and she
kisses him on the neck and I was like
that was weird I was like that was
really weird that you kissed your friend
on the neck and then we uh we break up
and I only find out that she was
cheating on me because when I go back to
get my [__] out of the house she's at
school and I was like I'm not I had to
drive 5 hours to Indiana to my buddy's
place we're in Ohio I I have to make two
trips on the trip back I go while she's
at school like a I'm like I'm just going
to get in in and out I tell her I'm like
hey I'm just going to be there for 30
minutes she's like you're not going to
[__] see me are you serious like
you're being a child and I was like well
this is the window that I'm going to be
there and she goes oh well I was going
to go to the gym then and I was like
okay [__] you like this is over so I I'm
I'm packing my [__] up and I see this
camera that I had bought her it was the
first selfie camera it was [__]
expensive I was a broke college kid but
I bought her this camera and I had a
half a thought of like maybe I'll take
that camera back which I didn't end up
doing it but I look through some of the
pictures and it's them like making out
and stuff like on the selfie camera
after we had I it was like two days
after and I was like oh this has been a
thing the whole [__] time so she was
doing that the whole time going Ohio
made you move anyway I don't think I
think it started after I moved to Ohio I
think she was like this guy's a [__]
loser he drives to Columbus three nights
a week to do standup open mics uh what
the [__] am I doing I'm gonna be a
doctor like uh and so I mean now they're
married I think yeah yeah so she
probably did the right thing but it
[__] my life up for for a little bit
cuz it was like I based my whole life on
that for a little bit and then it was
nice cuz I had a buddy who was like now
just do stand up he's like stand up is
your thing now because I went on stage
and just talked about it and it went all
right and he was like that's the most
interesting thing you've ever said and
so just do that from now on uh and that
changed my life like that made me a
commedian because I was doing standup
but I wasn't doing comedy because when
you're just talking about like so I read
the newspaper today and this happened
there are funny people who can do that
it's not something I ever seek out like
and I also don't think all your comedy
has to be trauma or something I think it
should be either very absurd or or very
real you know what I mean uh not that I
mean there's room for all of it but my
favorite comedy is the stuff that's like
really incisive and comes from a very
like real thing you know what I mean and
so for me that was that I was like oh
now I have real [__] to to talk about
and then it opened up the world of like
oh now I can talk about my dad and my
whatever you know uh if that makes any
sense I feel like I just threw a lot of
[__] at you well going back to your
biological dad you said you can talk
about your dad does anyone in his family
ever reached out or anything like that
no I don't know if anybody's alive I
don't know if they knew about me no okay
that's another thing yeah I don't know
uh I've the only person from his past
life to reach out to me is an ex of his
who like I said she wanted me to drop
this lawsuit and every once a while I'm
like maybe I should like look it up the
last name is pretty uncommon apparently
so it's like I could look into it I do
kind of want to go out there and just
see and I will say to Indian People's
Credit every time I talk about this [__]
on stage and I make fun of Indian people
because of it because I'm like this is
what Indian people do and I just use my
dad as the example but then I'll go uh
I'll say I'll say that on stage and make
fun of them and after the show they
almost always if there's Indian people
in the crowd someone will come up to me
be like hey man I will take you to India
dog like let's go really yeah yeah
they're like this is [__] up like and
also like Indian people if you're Indian
and you say I'm Indian Indian people
want to claim you they are like you are
one of us and so CU I didn't have him my
life I would go on stage and feel like
kind of fraudulent as like well I'm not
Indian enough I'm not white enough I'm
not anything and then they would be like
what the [__] are you talking about
you're Indian like if you are half
Indian you are Indian come to India and
I'll show you the world like they're
proud of they want you to like India you
know uh are you g to go I do want to go
at some point and what do you think
you'll see there the Taj Mahal I don't
[__] know I mean anything family from
your fathers or anything over there you
know if there's property or anything
still over there that's a great question
you know I never even thought of that
really there's probably like a house out
there or something something yeah I
somebody stole it from you
I mean it's not that's not that wouldn't
be mine but like if I I never thought
about that I should I would like to like
see where you're close with your mom oh
yeah very close what about taking a trip
with your mom I don't know if she would
be interested in that but uh she could
see India also yeah I don't think she
likes she barely likes to travel to La I
don't know yeah she met your step the
your dad and the ads and your stepdad
work down the street you don't have to
travel too far for
it
tell me about your mom though she sounds
like a strong lady I mean go through all
that is dude every therapist I've ever
had it's been like if it wasn't for your
mom you would be a [__] psychopath
because it's like and my wife said that
too she was like I told her this stuff
not immediately I didn't come out of the
game you you got to ease in you got to
ease in this
[__] you got to ease in you cannot come
out of the it can't be Buble and stuff
the top episodes you know what I mean
let's ease
into man I really hope I didn't up upset
people with that stuff I now I'm like in
my head but it's you didn't your stepdad
did I know I know but it's like I could
see people I had to turn it off after he
[__] said this thing but it's it's
just the real reality of it see here's
the thing that for the people watching
and listening is they get to turn it off
you didn't get to turn that off you had
to live that life yeah yeah that's it's
your life that's true yeah I just don't
want to [__] up your show I don't know
uh for a week or whatever but um yeah my
mom is awesome like she's very strong
she had kids when she was 15 damn um my
older uh my older brother and then my
older sister two years later so she had
to figure [__] out early and there there
is not money where I come from like that
we didn't come from anything and so she
had to work her way up she was working
full-time at Red Lobster when I was born
and then she worked her way through
nursing school and then she became a
nurse when I was like maybe nine or
something like that I don't I don't
remember the exact years but like then
she worked [__] 80 hours a week
that's the thing is she was trying to
like figure [__] out so she was working
a lot uh which is why I was like kind of
stuck with this psycho all the time and
so I had to like JY loop at night man
you know what I'm saying yeah I wish
they had night shft Jiffy Loop man that
would have fixed a lot of my life if
Jiffy Lube would have just been 247 why
can't there be a graveyard shifted Jiffy
Lube uh
yeah
that would have been good but no so uh
now she's worked her way into like she's
a nurse practitioner she's like doing
great she's uh I'm very proud of her and
like it's funny I would like help her
with her homework while I was doing my
homework she was like you know working
full- time and going to school full-time
um yeah she's [__] awesome she's
great um she's like raising another baby
now yeah uh so she's like I've I've
never met anybody with as much like
drive as she has and like she does not
relax like I mean she'll watch like a TV
show sometimes but like she like Works
her [__] ass off and so it always put
a thing under me I don't know if like if
you feel like work ethically or it's it
feels like it never ends because I'm
just like if I take a second off I'm
like what the [__] am I doing like I'm
I'm terrible at relaxing I'm horrible at
vacations cuz as soon as I'm on I'm like
what are we doing I should there I can
be doing more yeah I should be doing
more and the truth is you're right where
you should be you should be doing less I
know it's tough man it's tough not to
focus on like well I could be I could
have this many more followers if I
posted this today like and then it's
like I hate that [__] I don't know but
it's I we pick jobs where there's no
boss to tell you hey man you're done for
the day and so I think I got that from
her a little bit we talk about that a
lot where I'm like like I don't
understand how people don't feel like
this all the time you know uh and she's
like yeah me neither man but you should
and then she'll always tell me to chill
but she does how often do you get to see
her uh like twice a year maybe three
times cuz I go back to Indiana a lot to
do I'll do the comedy addict when I'm
back sometimes I'll do the holidays
she's going to come to here for uh to
see my new house uh in a couple weeks
which is exciting cuz she doesn't I
think like she came out for my wedding
last year
in New York but it's hard to get my
family to travel part of it she's busy
all the time too so it's hard to get a
day off you
know my bad shouldn't have drink at the
same time the dead air yeah uh man this
shit's int I'm like
sweating I feel so bad if you have to
edit that [__] out you C out we're not
cutting it out it's what happened I
don't look here's the other thing I
don't this show is different than just
hang you know if we were hanging and you
said that fine but this show is about
what you went through and the like I I
got to say I don't know no one's ever
come on here and talked about someone
doing that to animals and then telling
the kid like I did this and I did that
and I SM where's Rex I smashed his head
like yeah that's [__] it's a wonder
you're not a psycho well that's like I'm
I'm grateful that like I somehow
shielded myself from like not I think
it's because I would watch I use like TV
as an escape and so that kind of can
normal you out a little bit like you're
watching sitcoms and and standup and so
you get to see like oh this is how
normal adults act or like what I'm going
through is not regular you know it's
it's [__] weird and now you also
realize how [__] up it is that you're
looking at comics and going this is
normal that's how [__] up your sh yeah
that is why like you know what I'm
saying a great Point not this feels way
better than this does yeah you're just
like a 9-year-old watching Mark Maron
talk about whatever you're like this is
regular yeah this is this is fine um
dude this has been a great episode thank
you for coming on thanks for having me
man this is uh this I love this show and
like that that's uh I've never said most
of this stuff to like not not all not
only like on you know a mic or whatever
but just to most people but you like you
a gift to to [__] open people up so
Tom yeah thanks for having me brother um
well before we wrap up let me ask you
after everything we've talked about now
this is going to be interesting advice
you would give to your 16-year-old self
oh man I forgot about that you said that
earlier and then I got lost in my own
[__] I would say the thing that
changed my life uh for the better is
when I really took in like you're going
to die someday like there's in 200 years
you will be nothing and
so use that to your advantage like don't
be afraid of anything like I was I was
really afraid of like embarrassing
myself socially as a kid and I think
like by taking risks like even doing
standup I wish I had done it earlier
like uh like a lot like Chappelle doing
it a 14 or something if you think like
you know I want to do something but I'm
like I'm shy whatever get over that [__]
it's you're going to be dust in 200
years so keep that in mind I know it's
not a positive like it's not always a
positive for everybody for me it was a
big positive it's the reason I started
stand up is I was like I want to do this
and I'm so scared uh of it going bad or
that I'll have some sort of fear on
stage or something and then it's like
who gives a [__] uh yeah that and uh
play sports more I don't know yeah and
never and I played too many video
games get out of the house but a lot of
this was out of my control but remember
you're going to die and let it motivate
you hell yeah that might have been an
insane thing to say I don't know I'm off
the rails um One More Time plug and
promote whatever you like yeah uh Tom
takar uh on all the socials th ha kka R
I promise I won't say uh anything too
disturbing on there and uh and then yeah
the special's on YouTube now and
wherever you get your albums except for
Spotify and that is takar Noir t h a k k
a r n o i r and stand by B the podcast
get on those all right thank you very
much for being here it's a great episode
don't overthink it you're good to go uh
as always Ryan sichler on all your
social media Ryan sikler
docomond the road again tickets at
ransler we'll talk to you all next
[Music]
[Applause]
week
[Music]
n